so happy that i get to talk about it now
i snuck into a theater on opening night
and just watched from like with my
baseball cap on my mask and just kind of
like in fact i was actually with toby me
and toby snuck into a theater together
no one knew we were there
it was just a really beautiful thing to
share together and to find a brotherhood
with toby as well and with tom and and
the fact that we have shared a very
unique experience like first and
foremost i am a fan so when amy pascal
and kevin feige and and john watts asked
to have a word with me and talk to me
about an idea and they and they pitched
it it was like your little head just
explodes i was the fans in the audience
watching it on screen for the first time
with like the three spider-men across
universes are sharing a frame together
and then the fact that i get to be one
of those people wearing the suit next to
my actual spider-man hero toby maguire
and the brilliant incredibly talented
heartfelt funny good sweet perfect
spiderman of tom holland and i get to be
the middle brother and i get to be like
in awe of my older brother and in full
longing to protect my younger brother
i mean you know never say never i mean
it's a character that's always gonna be
so meaningful to me and so beautiful to
me and again it comes back to service i
think if there's a way
for me to continue to add to the legacy
of that character in a way that feels of
service to an audience of service to the
themes that stan lee you know injected
that character with i'm open of course
i'm very very open but but it would have
to be very very special it would have to
be very very
meaningful and fun and joyful